let's see let's go next to our caller
from the 6:00 to 3:00 area code who is
calling today from 6:00 to 3:00
uh hello yeah that's you oh hi this is
Ricky from Phoenix hey so I have a
question
I saw the question because lately on
your say I've been saying uh it
shouldn't be a taboo talking about
religion and politics in the table right
um so yes I've been trying to talk to
people like you know like at work and
you know my family my friends about
politics and they get really Superman so
I'm just like well we should probably
have these discussions now because it is
kind of a bad time so how would you
approach that well what do they get like
give me an example so Ricky you decide
to bring something up with like a family
member what do you bring up and then how
do they respond so when the stimulus
sticks came in and Trump had a letter
with the stimulus chicks come in like in
the mail yeah there were like oh this is
a nice thing to do it's like don't you
think that that's a bit propaganda and
they are gone mad I mean they're all
like less supporters but they don't know
anything about politics so I just
brought their question like don't you
things a bit propaganda so here's an
idea on that one that's a good that's a
good one
with the way you might approach it would
be instead to try to get them thinking
instead of saying don't you think that
this is just propaganda you could say
that's interesting you know everything
the government does costs money do you
think this is a good use of taxpayer
money to send these letters and then
maybe they say yeah I do and then you
say okay that's interesting how do you
decide if something is a good use of
taxpayer money the point is it's not so
much about which questions you ask but
just get them thinking about how they
came to these conclusions because I
agree with you this letter is is totally
propagandistic but by starting to call
it propaganda I probably won't convince
too many people instead if I get it to
think about we have limited funds you
know if they care about debt say we're
in debt we have a pandemic this cost
money like that is you're saying this
isn't it this is a good okay use of
money when the money could have gone to
something other than sending all of
these letters out to people
I would maybe approach it that way than
just calling it what by the way I agree
with you it's propaganda but yeah you
probably aren't going to convince too
many people like that no because you
know I do say some things and I do think
I'm on the ball when I come from a
response bum just like maybe I could
have approached it a different way
yeah do you know it's good to be
thinking about it about that listen
Ricky Arizona has one of the worst
coronavirus case growth rates in the
world right now how are you living it
down there is it if my friends in
Arizona are saying it's like business as
usual just everything's open and
nobody's wearing masks yeah no I worked
at a Sam's Club right well you know vibe
I mean gonna happen we don't have a mask
policy going on everybody's going out
freely everybody's going to the gyms
it's really really bad like I recently
went on a date and we went and we went
to like a lake me and my date and and
nobody was wearing masks people weren't
social distancing so it was kind of
worrying for us I mean we did try to
just social distance places thank your
friends said it's business as usual
nothing is changing at all are people
even talking like our people so there's
people who are not wearing masks as if
everything's fine and nothing's going on
there's also people who are sometimes
not wearing masks because they're aware
of what's going on but they think it's
like a hoax or not not really a problem
which is it more of would you say people
who are just like on cloud nine and
aren't even aware or people who have
decided like I don't need to wear a mask
right now it's I don't need to wear a
mask I think the majority of people I
talk to I don't need to wear a mess oh
yeah Wow
all right Ricky good luck down there in
Phoenix thank you and good luck I'm a
fan of the show I just recently became a
member so thank you I appreciate that -
all right Ricky take care great to hear
from you